[Music]
good afternoon welcome back to the
closing keynote here future decoded my
name's Steve Clayton
I'm the chief storyteller at Microsoft
and it's the second time I've been up on
this stage and it's great to be back in
the UK where I'm originally from
despite the slightly odd accents that
sit somewhere between here and Redmond
these days but I'm excited this
afternoon to take you on this journey
the story of quantum computing you heard
this morning you saw this slide actually
from panels and he talked about these
three trends in technology and in fact
in chapter six of this book hit
refreshed that hopefully some of you may
have seen or read that Sacher published
last month so Sachin adela writes in
this book in Chapter six he calls it
beyond the cloud and when he talks about
beyond the cloud he talks about these
three technology areas and you've heard
a great deal at least about the first
two today and maybe some of you have
been to the breakout sessions we've had
today on quantum computing you've heard
about mixed reality you've heard about
artificial intelligence how it's being
infused throughout all of Microsoft's
products and is going to be this tidal
wave of technology in all of our
products and services over the next few
years but we're gonna spend the next 45
minutes or so talking about quantum
computing and this is a radically
different thing so if any of you are sat
out there with your red hat on you got
from the Expo from Red Hat it's time to
hold on to your hat because this is a
completely different field of Technology
it's a phenomenally exciting area of
technology I'm excited to be able to
bring two of our greatest researchers to
talk about it here today but a little
bit of why are we talking about quantum
computing why in fact does the world
need quantum computing we have enormous
computing capability today in Asia 40
Asia regions around the world each of
those regions capable of being able to
in the data center the size of each of
those data centers could store 16 jumbo
jets so we're not sure too
computing power we have almost infinite
computing power but there are still some
technology challenges that are outside
of the scope of that computing power if
we want to see Blue Planet three then
we're gonna have to do some work around
climate change and quantum computing
could be the technology to help us
unlock some of those challenges around
climate change we want to have
breakthroughs in food production to
enable all of the planet to be able to
eat and have a healthy diet and to be
able to simply have food quantum
computing again could be the technology
to unlock some of the breakthroughs in
that field and if we want to find work
around antibiotic resistance in medicine
and healthcare some of the challenges
that still lie there they are still
grand challenges that can't be solved
with today's classical computers so
that's why we're here today to talk
about quantum computing to sort of go
under the covers a little bit to
understand what this technology is all
about and why it will unlock those
frontiers of technology and frontiers of
grand challenges that we have as a
society now Microsoft has amassed a
dream team literally our global quantum
dream team operates around the globe
from redmond to the netherlands the UK
to sydney across the globe we have a
team of some of the leading experts in
the world on quantum and i'm delighted
to have two of them here today to take
you down under the covers and explain a
little bit what this technology is all
about and this is what we're going to
talk about over the next 45 minutes or
so why quantum computing is different it
literally is a fundamentally different
type of computing how Microsoft is
building a quantum computer how our
approach is unique there are other
companies other industries who are
looking at quantum computers there's
been lots of news around it recently but
Microsoft is genuinely taking a unique
approach in something we call the
topological qubit that you'll hear about
in the next few moments and we'll talk
about some of these grand challenges and
how we'll be able to address them using
the power of quantum computing
so let's get started quantum computing
really is different most of us in the
room probably know about classical bits
about ones and zeros we're gonna hear a
little bit about quantum bits and how
they are dramatically different down at
the physical level down at the atomic
level to allow us to build these quantum
computers so it gives me great pleasure
to welcome a friend of mine dr. Leo
Cohen joven from our research institutes
in the Netherlands to come and talk a
little bit about the first part of this
story
please welcome Leo to the stage
[Music]
thank you Steve let me start by noting
that for about four thousand years the
principle of encoding information and
calculating of information hasn't
changed much but removing balls in the
abacus from left to right or move around
Baro bits of zeros and ones in a modern
shape the principles are the same
left-right zero one different names for
the same principle if however we move to
quantum computers then we're actually
going to start building entirely new
building blocks start with new
principles to build a bigger computer
and these new quantum building blocks
actually fit better to attack some of
the problems that at this moment are
still unsolvable and it's this classical
IT that were using at the moment does
have some limits how we're bound to
encoding informations to zeros and ones
and for some of the problems that we're
using it for its amazingly fast a search
on the Internet is very very fast it's
amazing but let me give you an example
when classical IT actually has sincere
limits here you see a supercomputer
somewhere located in China and it can
calculate the chemical properties of
small molecules for instance the
molecule of for coffee caffeine however
if I make the molecule slightly bigger
for instance this iron molybdenum
complex it's only slightly bigger the
computer can no longer calculate the
chemical behavior of that molecule
somehow chemistry is a problem that
scales very poorly on the classical IT
now biology is full of larger molecules
that are completely out of reach for an
understanding based on a computation for
quantum mechanics or quantum IT the
principles of the quantum mechanics is
that we're actually you know invented or
thought about in the context of small
particles phrases in the context
how Adams glued together and form
molecules in fact chemistry is just one
of the applications of quantum mechanics
and that includes all of chemistry
including all the chemistry in our
bodies so can we use these powerful
principles of quantum mechanics whatever
they are for IT and solve problems that
are currently still unsolvable now let's
see what one of the founders of quantum
theory says this is Richard Feynman
[Music]
now actually recognize these laughing
students I remember it for my physics
class in general relativity where maybe
scored something like a b-plus and could
even have been B - although - B - I
still felt that I understood the
principles for quantum mechanics even
after years of working in the same field
I got used to it but still if my
colleagues were arguing about the
fundamental interpretation still
everyday so it's a very different type
of theory it's counter intuitive it's
weird and as Richard Feynman says you
know it's safe to say that nobody
understands quantum mechanics a final
ended are saying something about the
need to have quantum mechanics for
understanding nature and in particular
understanding the beauty of nature
nature speaks the language of quantum
mechanics to understand simple things
like white grass is green or why a leaf
is green
we need quantum mechanics we need to
counter intuitive principles of quantum
mechanics and to illustrate this a
little bit let me just take a very
simple molecule oxygen our two oxygen
atoms are bound together by a covalent
bond and form o - and the bond comes
from sharing a single electron over the
two oxygen atoms and this sharing is not
done by putting the electron just in the
middle between the two atoms it's also
not done by having the electron jumping
back and forth between the two atoms
it occurs by the electron or the
electron makes it happen by splitting
itself up and sit on the same at the
same time on the two different atoms
simultaneously it can occupy the two
different atoms at different locations
it can be in two different positions at
the same time that is one of those weird
quantum mechanical principles that we
superposition now atoms are small so no
we're not really impressed if an
electron sits at two different positions
within a molecule but we've extended
these principles in small transistor
devices we've been able within
semiconductor material to make small
boxes that can hold exactly one single
electron now in when we make devices if
two boxes with one electron we can
actually encode information whether the
electro sits in the left box or in the
right box left box that says qubit zero
or a bit zero and right box is a bit one
now if we set ourselves up if we set
ourselves up yeah we're setting
ourselves up for having just one
electron in the left box now if we make
the device similar as we know what
happens in nature the actor can actually
split itself up a form of superposition
and occupy both boxes at the same time
now this no longer is restricted to the
atomic scale like the angstrom scale
this now extends over micrometers we can
scale up the length scale to micrometers
as we need for ordinary computing
devices the super position of having the
electron both in the left box in the
right box is what we call the quantum
bit or a qubit now we have encoded in a
zero and the one at the same time it's
not just either 0 or 1
it's 0 & 1 at the same time and this
superposition can I Ella straight why
this is actually useful for computation
if you think about the problem of a maze
and the problem of the maze the way we
solve it is that we just we try unto
success sequentially until success if we
have to success when we know that we
have success which we found the answer
but we try sequentially if we can make
use of a superposition then we can just
try all paths all possible paths at once
reaching success a lot fast
so doing computations in parallel can
reach for at least four certain problems
success much faster now qubits quantum
bits you may have heard the story of
Schrodinger's cat Schrodinger's cat that
can be dead or alive at the same time
it's it's a it's popularized in many
texts and many you know popular writings
on quantum mechanics now we will not be
using cats in our computers cats will
not be the qubits in our computers we
will use a quantum particle that was
first proposed by an Italian physicist
and somehow it was a signal when Italian
physicist a Tour de Marana and they told
my Arana
predicted the particle in 1937 a
mysterious particle it was actually
never detected until a few years ago and
normal particles like an electron have a
charge and a spin the spin is kind of a
magnetic moment that can point up or
down so a little magnet here you see
that beam or illustrates that we can
make a superposition of an electron spin
and in this example it's about 70% up
30% down but as you can see it Wiggles a
little bit there's noise around it's
average and the noise is unavoidable
because there are always other electrons
nearby and all the other electrons also
have spins and are all interacting just
the same as magnets are interacting a
little bit of each other so the quantum
information that we had originally
stored in that one first electron is now
leaking out to all the other electrons
to all the other spins in the
environment
we're losing the quantum information
which makes it very difficult to perform
long calculations now how can we prevent
this am i Ron had an idea that I'd like
to illustrate it is metaphor of
breakdancers
imagine that you're holding your
neighbor then that freezes out all the
motion between the dancers only the two
dancers at the very end can make some
strange movements the rest is moving as
one collective unit can we do something
similar with electrons
the idea is that all the electrons in
the middle hole each other and that only
the two electrons at the very end can
have some motion have some freedom for
motion and this was exactly Maya Ranas
idea he was thinking about a row of
electrons for instance you can imagine
it as a row of electrons occupying a row
of seeds now you could actually do a
little experiment by if there's a row of
C that is completely filled except for
one chair then if everybody sits over
goes over by one chair what happens to
the empty seat is that it jumps over to
the very other end so by a collective
motion of what moving over one chair the
empty seat moves over a long distance
and also for these electrons if all the
electrons move over one site the empty
space moves over to the other end and
this can happen back and forth now we're
not doing a classical movement of the
empty chair we can in fact make use of a
superposition what the superposition
allows you to do is that the empty chair
is actually at the same time left and
right the electron one of the electrons
actually splits up in two pieces
it's fractures and the two pieces are
now at the very end of the system where
there's still some freedom of motion
this is again what we call the super
position of the electron state occupying
two very far separated sites now this
long separation effectively disconnects
the two quantum states and it provides a
protection
it's what we call a topological
protection for leaking the quanta for me
with the quantum information into the
rest of the environment and these two
end States are known as the Maya Rana
particles predicted in 1937 but only
detected in 1900 or 2012 in our lab in
the Netherlands so this is my Arana bit
because of the separation of the quantum
information that is now protected
becomes a very stable robust building
block for making a qubit and if you have
a robust building block for a qubit then
scaling to a circuit to a full-scale
quantum computer becomes a lot easier
it's about normal electrons or normal
qubits if you want to scale it up it's
like building a house of cards it's a
nightmare for engineers well if you have
a Lego building block it's going to be
fun to build up to lot at larger
structures and that's exactly what what
we want to do we are engineers and we
like to build things and it was not a
famous sake from Richard Feynman then
he's once said like shut up and
calculate we've changed it in the slogan
shut up and engineer and this is exactly
what we are doing at this very moment
built qubits build quantum circuits now
how we do that and to give you an
impression what the daily life is in our
laboratory I want to show you a little
movie
he sent me in the Kleagle just call me
take of our the cubits of Markuson he's
having in mashaallah I thanked him but
their omelet clearly so I could you tell
stop mutters taken to the level Horner
and flux abstraction it wouldn't lift
the pool of the lack of order for a
minute and he kicked yourself a buckin
year so horrible chip the tip you can
indeed apparatus open you got on over
tip you about the Deutsche's - and
daughter I'm about paternity is mirror
of the computer Phil ever cubits mark
exactly company the basses Patrona but
would on extra so Janine Hale hold up
Raph me mark were hanging a sign in
Montreal accent hated dinner drag kiss
the children aside done on high the nano
track is also cinnamon D booted off the
chica Coleman on the qubit him after
Monica he is I'm in the mate hole
favorite pump computers tester Israel's
all of I hear and it's cold I'm not
ready deform computer mood off coolant
in a row two hookers I hate Eliza temple
tutor clock back up certain open so she
to the computer are the cool cost and
Davina
sit on a little tone ship met all the
qubits
pretty cool huh
does everyone following along alright
there's gonna be a test at the end for
sure you don't get to leave the room
unless you can explain am I on a
particle but Leia I wanted say thank you
we're gonna invite you back on for some
more Q&A later but I was following along
there was an error in the video I think
around the temperature you found an
error I did I saw an error in the video
can you explain it good job yeah so
somehow lost in translation I was saying
in Dutch absolute zero temperature and
was translated as absolute or zero
Celsius that's not absolute zero
temperature zero Kelvin which is about
two 273 degrees below zero
that is what we call absolute zero okay
it's about a challenge for making a farm
computer we have two pulley down to very
very very low temperatures all right
anything we're gonna hear more about in
a moment and we'll see you later thank
you so much big handful lay oh please
everyone
so they're genuinely will be a test
later on you don't get to leave without
passing the test but I am gonna try and
summarize it for you briefly right now
so let me give this a go I think so far
if I'm following along correctly in
quantum computing terms it is computer
says no and yes at the same time no
didn't work well it's my vague attempt
that a joke didn't work maybe we will
just move on so we're gonna take you
into the second part of the story the
twist in the story around these qubits
why are the qubits that Microsoft is
trying to create so special and so
different and it is a very different
approach that we are taking simply to
say that our qubits Microsoft qubits I'd
not like anybody else's qubits in this
quantum journey and so nobody better to
come and talk to you about that why
we're building these qubits how we're
building them then dr. christow story so
please welcome Krista to the stage
[Music]
tell you about the software the tools
that were going to use to program this
amazing quantum computer and the qubits
that leo has just showed to you and and
the large comprehensive stack so let's
talk more about this here we go so at
Microsoft's were working on developing
the complete quantum computer a
comprehensive stack that spans
everything from the hardware the qubits
the cryogenic control to the software
the programming languages you're going
to use to write your quantum programs
and to ask the quantum computer to give
you solutions to some of the world's
most challenging problems we're working
on a universal programmable quantum
computer and we're identifying the
revolutionary applications that you'll
be able to run on it so in addition to
the qubit as we heard from Leo the
topological qubit that's going to sit at
the very coldest temperatures
millikelvin temperatures inside this
dilution refrigerator in addition to
that we're building a cryogenic
classical computer this is unlike any
classical computer we have today it will
run around four Kelvin you know around
minus 459 degrees Fahrenheit and this
classical computer will control and help
program and control the quantum chips
that sit at millikelvin temperatures and
then of course in addition to the
hardware we need software right software
to program and control the quantum
computer and at Microsoft of course
we're also developing the software stack
to enable programming and controlling
this quantum computer at scale to large
numbers of qubits to large powerful
computational algorithms now this system
we'll sit in the cloud right these
delusion refrigerators are life-sized
you know is larger than me and they're
not gonna sit in your in your office at
work they're definitely not going to sit
in your pocket like your mobile device
right it's gonna sit in the cloud it's
gonna be one of the accelerator options
in Microsoft's cloud in Azure so just as
today you have options to send your
algorithms and applications to a mix of
GPUs CPUs FPGAs quantum will be one of
those options for you as you think about
accelerating applications for your
businesses now let's talk a little bit
more about how these qubits work about
the topological qubit and this comes to
error-correction not all qubits are
created equal and so we need to speak
about error correction error correction
is one of the fundamental concepts in
computer science something we're using
every day and technology for example
fault tolerance and error correction is
fundamental to cd-roms hard disks how we
protect memory and the underlying
information we want to store in it this
is also true of our quantum computer we
also need forms of error correction and
we want to use error correction in a way
that makes it very efficient to protect
our qubits and protect the quantum
information quantum computers after all
are far more susceptible to noise which
is why of course we're running them in a
very cold dilution refrigerator to
protect them from thermal noise fault
tolerance and error correction is
critical to think about as we build up
this comprehensive large-scale quantum
computer so not all qubits are created
equal we're working on what's called a
topological qubit and it has very
distinct error correction properties so
on this plot here we have on the x axis
number of qubits and on the y-axis we
have error rate now if we move along the
x-axis if we just think about numbers of
qubits and we don't think about what
kind of qubits or how good they are
right you might think more qubits is
always better but more qubits are not
always better if they're not good enough
to actually handle the computations we
want to perform on these qubits we want
to scale and actually solve the world's
most challenging problems with these
qubits and so at Microsoft instead of
just pushing on getting more cubans we
instead push against the y-axis error
rate we want better qubits as
Leo mentioned the building block it's
critical that we choose the right
building block from which to scale out
our large quantum computer and so at
Microsoft we think about moving to lower
and lower air rates that is better and
better qubits that are robust against
noise and errors that have high fidelity
that are gonna allow us to scale to
large computations to solve the world's
most challenging problems the
topological qubit will get us there
better error rates better foundation
allows us to rapidly scale to large
numbers of really good qubits allowing
us to solve the world's hardest problems
this is pretty powerful the topological
qubit is key to scaling up rapidly and
solving these problems for our
businesses and for the world we're
talking about reliable computation in
the quantum computer reliable storage
and rapid scaling now you may be
wondering what am I going to do with
this and how does it work I want to give
a little bit more of an intuitive feel
for error correction on this topological
qubit before we jump to the applications
we're going to solve now you can imagine
to kind of to understand the robustness
of our qubit versus other types of
qubits let's say you want to keep track
of information and let's just pretend
we're living thousands of years ago we
didn't have computers and calc
leaders and all of that so one way is
you could leave marks on a rock say with
Chuck right so I could I could mark like
on the left I can mark chalk marks and
keep track alternatively I can take
lessons from the Incans and this
beautiful design on the right is called
a quipu and this is how the Incans
tracked information instead of marking
with chalk or drawing lines in the sand
they instead took string braids and
knotted them now you can probably
imagine why this is more powerful say
rain comes wind comes a storm comes
right if my information is stored in
chalk marks or drawings in the sand it
will wash away
I have no protection against that storm
but if I had stored my information in
knots
this is robust to a storm now in fact
this analogy is even closer than you may
think
our topological qubits in fact are not
sand braids in mathematics we talk about
topology and in fact our qubit relies on
topology on this area of mathematics
which in fact relies on knots and braids
to compute knots and braids in
space-time rather than of course in just
a physical string
soleio mentioned this qubit right it's
it's it relies on these fractionalized
electrons to store our information and
they're stored you know in a sense
across the string of electrons right now
if we want to compute with this this set
of electrons with this this qubit this
type of qubit envision it like a string
and now let's take a few of them and now
I'm gonna start my computation and it's
just like a braid in time I start to
braid the information from the qubits
and I can create these intricate
patterns just like the Incans did with
their quipu and in fact these patterns
code my quantum algorithm and allow me
to complete complex operations and solve
very challenging problems and it does so
in a protected way soleio showed these
wiggling electrons right the Wiggles and
his slides imagine these strings are
wiggling like a jump rope if I wiggle
the strings of my braid it doesn't
change the braid it's protected against
that kind of noise this wiggling noise
and that's the key this is far more
robust than other types of qubits and
other types of quantum computation
because it's robust against these local
noise effects now in terms of the
problems we want to solve with this
quantum computer here's one here's a
2048-bit number and this problem
underlies the mainstay of e-commerce
today this is how we encrypt your credit
card when it goes on the internet for
example and you're purchasing something
right this is the this is underlies RSA
cryptosystem
now if you can tell me the two primes
that I multiplied together to get this
number you would probably have a lot
more money because you'd know everyone's
everyone's credit card numbers this is a
hard problem classically the reason we
rely on this problem it's a one-way
function and it's hard it takes a
billion years to find those two prime
numbers that I multiplied together on a
classical computer quantumly we're
talking about just 100 seconds ok but
fear not we have ways new ways to encode
your information in a quanta you know
once we have quantum computers we call
this post quantum crypto so while RSA
will be broken by a quantum computer we
have methods you will turn to that we
should start turning to now to protect
the information against a quantum
computer so indeed there are crypto
systems that are robust against quantum
attacks and we should all start changing
to those systems now now that's one
interesting problem you can see the
scale of speed-up we get from the
quantum computer the
let's look to other applications if we
take how do we you know when we look at
molecules we want to understand chemical
reaction rates
well classically this is an exponential
time problem and we're looking at age of
the universe to find solutions if we
want to find the ground state energy of
a molecule we want to understand
reaction rates even if we come up with a
better algorithm on better hardware
let's say we get an exascale
supercomputer in the next 10 years we're
barely moving the needle here in terms
of the time the calculation time on a
quantum computer however we have amazing
scaling polynomial time scaling and this
means we're looking at days maybe weeks
for a solution as opposed to billions
and billions of years for a solution on
the classical computers this allows us
to solve some of the world's most
challenging problems the key behind this
is the exponential scaling of your
qubits of the quantum computer at 30
cubits seems like a small number 30
cubits to simulate that classically
requires 16 gigabytes of RAM of memory
now if I add 10 qubits I moved to 40
qubits that doesn't just linearly grow
it requires a thousand times more memory
for 40 qubits that's 16 terabytes let's
add 10 more that's a thousand times more
memory again 16 petabytes to simulate 50
cubits now if I move to something like
two hundred sixty cubits I'm looking at
more atoms than there are in the visible
universe that's a pretty powerful
machine now that's only 260 qubits we're
talking about scaling to thousands with
Microsoft's quantum computer imagine the
power that power we can use to solve
very challenging problems problems like
nitrogen fixation why do we care about
nitrogen fixation artificial fertilizer
production helping with the world's
hunger we want a more efficiently
produce fertilizer currently
we use a process from the early 1900's
it consumes something like 3% of the
world's natural gas just for fertilizer
let's improve that we can use our
quantum computer to improve that by
finding a catalyst to make that reaction
more efficient
similarly in carbon capture we can look
to find a catalyst to help us extract
carbon from the atmosphere improve and
take steps towards combating global
warming material science we can look to
improve clean energy solutions we can
study materials on the quantum computer
problems that take billions of years
classically we can solve in a matter of
days or weeks on our quantum computer
find a material that super conducts at
higher temperatures enabling say
lossless power transmission and in
machine learning we can look to nature
nature that all we you know already is
using quantum mechanics to do amazing
things every day what if we harness that
kind of problem you know that kind of
computation for machine learning imagine
how that transforms speech vision models
of users models of data as we use
quantum models to take machine learning
to an entirely new level now how am I
going to do all this without tools right
I entered quantum computing because I
wanted to find out how I could actually
program this device what kind of tools
do we need and I'm really thrilled to
announce that Microsoft is releasing a
quantum development toolset in preview
by the end of the year that allows you
to take this and program quantum
computers and develop quantum algorithms
it comes with a quantum programming
language specific to quantum computing
that really allows you to harness the
amazing quantum mechanical effects to
come up with solutions to your heart
problems
it comes integrated in Visual Studio you
get code colorization debugging the
ability to step through your program and
then just the ability to access it's
more accessible many have used Visual
Studio before of course and then it
comes with a quantum simulator so you
can test indeed
bug your quantum algorithms locally on
your PC as well as the quantum simulator
in Azure that allows you to scale and
test on more than 40 cubits so I
encourage all of you to join our quantum
community please sign up to gain access
to our software learn more about
Microsoft's comprehensive approach to
quantum computation at Microsoft comm
slash quantum I look forward to having
you join our Microsoft community and
helping us start and empower the quantum
revolution together thank you
all right so I think everybody in the
room now feels smarter than he did 40
minutes ago thank you so much Chris that
was fantastic I also want to invite Leo
back on stage and just ask a couple of
questions our before we wrap up the
session here so please welcome back
layout to the stage so we only have them
for a few more minutes because we've got
to get them back to the lab and to build
this quantum computer thing so on that
point layer were where we up through
were things that we've made we've been
analyst for 20 years but we're we're and
it seems like it's it's a pivotal time
it is and we actually now know what we
have to do so we assembled all the
necessary equipment you saw some of the
pictures of these giant stainless to
actually material growth machines we
hire the people people in material
science and engineering and
nanotechnology and in physics and we're
ready to build the system initial
experiments are successful we see the
right my arañas that are you know are
let's say robust they're very strong and
next step is to make the qubit ok I
asked the team about this recently I
said how's it going making the qubit and
they said we have some really good ones
wiggling in the fridge I wasn't quite
sure what that meant but it sounded cool
and so Krista tell us a little bit about
this this global team the importance of
the team that we've amassed and the
different backgrounds that come from
yeah so hopefully from this presentation
you can see the diverse set of tasks
that we have to tackle to realize a
comprehensive fully scaled out quantum
computer and this includes everything
from the qubit technology to engineering
the cryogenic control to a brand-new
cryogen a classical computer you know
all the way up to the software and then
the algorithms themselves and this
really does require a global dream team
a set of people that come from
mathematics physics from industry from
academia and so at Microsoft we've
really brought together people from a
diverse range of fields and a diverse
range of environments to tackle this
problem and bring forward a
comprehensive solution for quantum
computer
and so then in terms of next steps for
people you talked about a moment ago
we've got a set of technologies coming
how should people prepare for this
quantum era how should they be thinking
about it what can they go a lot more
well I think step one is visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides good won't
please a big hand again both Krista and
Leo I'll let you both get back to the
lab and to build a quantum computer hey
thank you so much
so I hope you enjoyed it I certainly
feel a lot smarter after spending time
hanging around with these folks it still
sort of blows my mind a little bit but
I'm starting to get my head around it
but just to summarize this is the
approach that Microsoft has taken it is
a revolutionary in fact unique approach
around this topological qubit to enable
us to create a qubit that requires much
less error correction a unique approach
also this global team that we built
around the world bringing together as
Krista said academics physicists
mathematics all into one dream team that
we think is on the cusp of doing
something magnificent with quantum
computing and then the final piece
building this scalable into end
technology scalable in the sense of
being able to not have to require
millions of qubits to do that error
correction but also scalable in the
sense that we're building this thing all
the way from the bottom of that
refrigerator the coldest place on earth
maybe coldest place in the universe all
the way to the top of that stack to
build the software and the tools in an
environment that you're familiar with
inside of Visual Studio to be able to go
and program the quantum computer just
the way that you program computers today
and so as Krista mentioned to learn more
about this I would encourage you to go
to Microsoft comm slash quantum we have
a set of resources newsletters that you
can sign up to and you can hear more
about the journey that we're on and hear
more about the announcements that we
will be making over the coming months so
I hope you enjoyed that session we're
gonna wrap it up here I'm gonna hand
back to Claire Berkeley or Co oh so
thank you so much for your time